president of the British Chamber of
Commerce in Spain and he joins us now
from Barcelona so good to see you sir
why the markets so convinced that this
crisis is going to be resolved do you
think well in that's gone along with
what the Spanish government said today
and they said that we're back to
business as usual that Spain will grower
over 3% GDP year-on-year over the full
year and so at the moment in Madrid
everyone's feeling relaxed not so much
the case here in Barcelona so what have
you been telling British businesses
based in Spain and in Catalonia in
particular well that we need to talk to
governments and make sure that we finish
with the uncertainty as soon as possible
we looked over the cliff edge on on
Friday and thankfully didn't fall off it
but we still to know what the what the
future path is if we've seen the peak of
uncertainty if we now move towards
democratic elections in December and
then a negotiated settlement so that
catalonia is comfortable with in spain
in the current day then we've seen the
worst of it and we'll just see slow
growth within a relatively rich region
and if there is further disruption if
there is further uncertainty if we see
civil disobedience over the next few
months or we just kicking the can down
the road then a british companies which
should the UK's the third largest direct
investor in Catalonia and as well as
other foreign countries are going to
start making other investment decisions
it should we be worried about British
investment in Catalonia you say there
were the third largest investor in the
region I mean it's is that investment in
danger at all well it depends on the
sector's a lot of the British investment
in Catalonia is in long term sectors
manufacturing especially the automotive
sector publishing a lot of service
industries so there won't be effective
in the short term and will only see
effects on that if there's continued
description from now on but there are a
lot of small and medium companies
invested in it in Catalonia obviously
they're planning to cope with brexit and
they're worried that if there isn't a
settlement if Catalonia does eventually
become independent then they'll be
outside of the European Union on on both
ends so the sector's we're seeing
short-term damages
are the ones related to foreign flows of
revenues so tourism in particular those
companies are worried and some 1,700
companies who would bet which were based
in Catalonia have now relocated to other
parts of Spain I mean that sounds fairly
sensible but does it put them at risk of
double taxation potentially in future
well it puts them at risk of double
taxation in the event of the the cliff
edge scenario and that's particularly
why those companies moved at the moment
it's only the registration that's moved
so those companies were worried that an
independent Catalonia the tried to
implement its independence as opposed to
the the symbolic political declaration
though we saw on Friday would mean the
Catalonia would start levying taxes
would stop putting their freeze on
capital so that's why a lot of
registered head offices moved and also
companies were moving their funds to
Madrid based banks now jobs haven't
followed so far it's too soon for that
so if we do see that things are calming
down that there is a path to a
negotiated solution I think at the end
of the day there won't be too much
damage and those companies essentially
they left because they wanted to
mitigate the risk
I'm not withstanding the statistics that
are trotted out prior to you coming on
there it's not widely known that whilst
people talk about Catalonia as being a
relatively wealthy area there are parts
of Spain that have a higher GDP per
capita I mean the Basque Country Navarre
and Madrid are all there wealthier on
that measure for example are we
overdoing the importance of Catalunya to
the Spanish economy no I don't think we
are it's very sectoral Madrid has a very
wealthy economy obviously but it's very
services based it's very based on on
multinationals what we have in Catalonia
is an industrial base that's very well
established that's very large we've also
got big banks of course it is
fundamental to the Spanish economy if
you measure it by year by GDP per capita
obviously it's quite a large and
populous region as well but certainly it
is of very substantial not just within
Spain but within Europe it's a very big
region it's a very of course of key
manufacturing centre rather than a
services centre like other parts of
Spain
yes absolutely it's also growing a
reputation with ink technologies there's
been a lot more innovation within
catalonia than other areas of Spain it's
sold itself as a startup hub and there's
a lot of synergies there with the UK
obviously there they've been attracting
a lot of talent and that's one of the
things that's concerning British
companies invested in in Catalonia
whether they'll still have the the
talent flows and be able to to import
the the skillsets that they'll need
especially within that technology area
all right Christopher dotty we've got to
leave it there I'm afraid thanks very
much for joining me it's good to see him